this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah thanks everyone for joining this is
episode eight of the Cornell Church show
here in season four Our Guest today is a
returning guest Sean kaister of Longwood
Gardens uh we're excited to talk to Sean
today this is sort of sustainability
week uh Sean gave us a laundry list of
things they are doing at Longwood
Gardens very exciting to talk to Sean
about all these different things and all
the logistics that's going to go uh into
these various initiatives so uh we're
going to get to conversation with Sean a
little bit uh but as always we'll we'll
hand it over to Frank Rossi here uh
Frankie got some thoughts on the growing
season uh we were just talking before
the show Ben polymer is getting readings
in the 90s in Massachusetts it's getting
hot it's getting dry soil saturation is
drying down we're seeing that on some of
our models uh so it's it's really gotten
it's gotten uh heavy quick here in in
the growing season yeah
um Earth Day is coming up when is it
tomorrow when is Earth Day Earth day is
tomorrow I think okay I think Earth day
is tomorrow uh April 15th or 14th the
same day as tax day right around the
same as tax day and then there's that
famous 420 holiday that you know half
the kids in Ithaca like uh for sure but
um welcome to the show and we're going
to get to our guest uh and actually he
probably notices this picture in the
background uh comes from his landscape
uh and to me it reminded me of a
wonderful Andrew Wyeth uh uh painting
right with that girl in the field
looking up on the hill it's a wonderful
picture but Sean I Googled you looking
for a picture and I I hate to say this
is what comes up so for people who don't
know you you want to be careful and then
this guy uh comes up uh and the things
that go on at Longwood Gardens uh but
you know really uh welcome just give you
an opening welcome here and then I want
to go through the growing season and
we're going to hear about all this
exciting stuff especially uh this new
AVP job you have congratulations on that
well deserved and since you had this
lovely blog post on Turf Care rooted in
data I thought we'd start out with some
of the data that you gave us years ago
about the first uh mowing date and as
you said so far it's been pretty dry
we've had a really dry week and
especially down where you are you're
touching that red area where the dry
conditions last week are starting to
build a little bit but that also means
the soils are starting to warm
everybody's warming up pretty quickly
and once that soil is consistently in
the 50 degree range you're going to get
some solid Greening up across the board
and I think that's exactly what we're
starting to see we had above normal
temps over you know week to week so
we're not necessarily capturing
everything that happened in the last
couple of days but yesterday as Carl
said in some areas 20 degrees above
normal we had our first night sitting
out on the porch having dinner at night
right you could it was the heat held on
even into the nighttime now when you
think about Turf growth right
everybody's excited right everybody
wants to get going but it's really just
getting going Sean how many modes have
you put on that Turf down there on your
finest Turf how many moves so we're
between two and three right now okay
good so you're you're not surging you're
just root now you've sort of hit routine
mowing right right perfect okay so where
we are in the mid if you're in the mid
50s you're still only at about 40 50
growth potential how much it can grow
and we're going to be having a new
growth model uh coming online soon that
we're still trying to work through and
validate uh these next couple of years
and it seems early I don't know how far
the dandelions are along uh it looks
like based on these models are degree
day models are saying you're just
creeping into the place where uh uh
broadly furbicide uh down in in your
neck of the woods would would maybe
start to be used it would be the Esther
formulation not the amine yet so again
these are sort of crude models here but
maybe crabgrass germination might just
be coming in the next couple of weeks uh
to the southern part of the region so
you know I like this as a timing for
folks listening because it this is a
time where you can use something like
diopir that that has some early post
activity so you could wait to see how
much pressure you're having and then if
you want to go out and make that
application you certainly can do it by
knowing when the germination is and it
looks like the trend of being above
normal and dry AI is is likely to keep
up for the next uh eight to ten days so
we are going to get some rain moving
through but it doesn't appear to be a
lot of moisture that's going to be
coming through for the next several days
so we talk about this all the time and
in honor of Earth Day and our honored
guests and my honored colleague who has
really taken the lead on this project
for us here in the program at Cornell uh
addressing the changing climate and
taking action here on the Cornell campus
so Carl I'll pass it to you now run this
I'll run the slides for you and then
I'll let you set up I got a little bit
at the end to set Sean up but feel free
to Banter the two of you because you
guys are knee-deep in this and I think
this is a A fitting topic Carl for Earth
Day uh Upon Us particularly in the
grounds area yeah and actually it's one
we've gotten questions on so uh Bill
Brewer I know Phil's on today uh one of
our uh very frequent live listeners sent
me a couple questions the other day and
one of them was about Turf and carbon
you know where does where does Turf
stand and in terms of sequestration
being a sink or a source of carbon
emissions right the public generally
views Lawns and turf as you know we're
mowing them a lot we're emitting these
greenhouse gases oh that's not good
um but there's this great review paper
Frank you talked on your Frankly
Speaking podcast with uh Claire Phillips
one of the authors on this on this paper
about uh when you look at the whole
system you know where do we stand and
they say you know it depends but a lot
of these a lot of the systems Turfgrass
systems mostly lawn less intensively
managed ones are either carbon neutral
or carbon sinks and that's because we do
a lot of of sinking of carbon through
the vegetative material right the
organic matter we're putting that into
the ground and we do a fair amount of
that it's really dependent on how
intensely we manage uh the landscape as
as to where we are are on that Spectrum
right and I come back to this uh to this
figure from ignatia about the Australian
group who does a lot with Urban Lawns
right if you look at the second one down
for those looking regulating ecosystem
Services they're on the positive side if
we're maintaining these appropriately
not too much we can get that carbon
sequestration benefit right you can see
that on the left side but if we're doing
uh too much mowing like gratuitous
mowing if we're applying too many
fertilizers which which can lead to
carbon emissions we might be a net
source of carbon right so it really
depends where we are in that Spectrum uh
in the last year and a half I've gotten
to work with Dan scheide our director of
grounds here at Cornell uh and as part
of this carbon offsets committee here at
Cornell we have a climate goal by 2035
to be carbon neutral we want to take a
look at our grounds and say hey what are
we doing to save on our greenhouse gas
emissions how can we reduce right one of
the very easiest ones is just a mow
higher right uh when you increase the
height of cut right if you're following
the one-third rule you've got more time
before you have to mount reduces your
mowing frequency we did some
calculations based on the research out
there and fuel use rates we raise it
about an inch over the last decade and
that leads to 20 percent less mowing we
save a certain amount per hectare that
that works out to about seven to ten
metric tons of carbon dioxide per year
across all our grounds
when there's these co-benefits and those
looking on the screen you can see two
houses two Landscapes one on the right
which has their their mowing height very
high one on the left which is is
scalping it down you can see some
drought stress there so there's these
co-benefits too that we that we like to
sort of quantify uh in addition to
carbon so you know mowing higher is one
thing we've done uh yesterday on the
Golf Show I mentioned these Tall Grass
these native areas whatever you want to
call them high rough uh we're doing that
on campus too so Dan has selected areas
across campus uh live slope probably one
of the most famous areas on campus where
we have Slope Day where there's a lot of
student traffic the really high sloped
areas that are difficult to mow that
people don't walk on anyway these
transition led to Meadows and again
we've calculated when you mow instead of
25 times a year only one time a year you
save a lot right so about four and a
half metric tons we've saved uh Dan's
got about 25 acres of this across campus
now and they look really beautiful uh
they have again these co-benefits storm
water uh they slow down storm water a
lot more infiltration there's more
pollinators uh and you know the
interesting thing Frank is is yesterday
preparing for yesterday's guest Mike
fedanza uh we're looking through some
research and guess who pops up Sean
keister and Mike fedanza in this paper
on uh the influence of grass species and
mowing practices on weed cover of
infrequently mowed grass stands right so
interesting to read that paper and Sean
you saw this firsthand obviously maybe
tall fescues these strong creeping red
feskies are pretty good for for those
areas so that's that's great to see too
and then you know one of the things that
the people don't think about when it
comes to turf grass maintenance is the
fertilizer you apply and that can
actually lead to some substantial
greenhouse gas emissions right so about
one percent it's hard to get a good
number on this about one percent of
fertilizer comes back out nitrogen
fertilizer comes back out of the system
as n2o gas nitrous oxide uh the reason
that's important is because nitrous
oxide is about 300 times more potent as
a greenhouse gas compared to carbon
dioxide so when you look at our
fertilizer rates across campus over the
years uh Dan has slowly uh reduced those
fertilizers rates and it's because of uh
you know the turf grass stand is
accumulated organic matter right it can
you see this this figure over here on
the right as as the year years go on
lawns accumulate that organic matter
they don't need as much nitrogen because
they can sort of recycle some of that
right especially if you're if you're
putting clippings back into the system
so this leads to some pretty big
reductions in greenhouse gases annually
33 and a half is is what we're
estimating from going from our previous
rates around two and a quarter pounds uh
per thousand to you know three quarters
of a pound per thousand
uh so the last one is electrification
right and Sean you're going down this
route as well uh we can Electrify the
small equipment right the blowers and
the trimmers uh we can get about three
and a half metric tons out of that here
at Cornell but the interesting thing is
you can calculate all these other
emissions that that are important to
human health and operator Health right
carbon monoxide hydrocarbons uh these
end up actually being the most
complicated way complication
calculations to figure out
um but you know in a given year we emit
about 1100 kilograms of carbon monoxide
because of the uh the trimmers and
blowers we use on campus and it would be
great to use electric versions of these
things because that you don't inhale any
of that stuff right so co-benefits again
not just uh carbon dioxide emissions but
operator health and safety right you
don't have to you don't have as loud too
that's a good thing
um and then of course the mowing Fleet
right so Wisconsin is retrofitting their
grounds operation with a bunch of these
ride-on electric Zero Turn Mowers they
The Operators seem to like those in the
first year again on campus we spend
about 41 metric tons of carbon dioxide
mowing the grounds every year you know
if you can if you can Electrify you
really decrease that number now Frank
it's not zero right it depends on where
your electricity is coming from again
Sean's gonna going to talk about some of
this stuff today but you can use the CPA
calculator based on your region in the
U.S how much of your electricity is
being produced by renewable resources
versus things like coal that produce
greenhouse gas emissions and you look at
us in Upstate New York we're pretty good
because we have a lot of renewable
energy uh that that's producing our
electricity whereas some of those places
downstate don't have that benefit right
so if you're transitioning to an
electric Fleet you're not getting quite
as much of the carbon benefit down there
as you are up here so so that's a real
brief overview of what Dan has been
doing on Cornell what I've been working
on just to really quantify what Dan's
been doing and this sort of leads us
into a conversation with you Sean about
your sustainability initiatives and
maybe where I'll start is uh oh we got
to start with a poem
of the planet we all must prize with
sustainable Pursuits they bear
eco-friendly fruits and Inspire us all
to be allies I absolutely love this
because the opportunity that Carl talks
about that we have here
to model this in a high profile area you
know I started out with this picture
right so you know no one looks at this
and says oh this looks sustainable to me
right Sean so you guys have had as Carl
said have had to be very intentional
about this and if you I would recommend
anybody that wants to know more after
we're done yakking over the next 10-15
minutes you can go to the Longwood
website because it's all spelled out
there this is a real sort of
organizational cultural thing Sean to
look at this and I think Carl that's
what you're caught up in here Cornell
has a larger carbon project that has
afforded us the opportunity to look at
our system in this particular way and
again you know there's a myriad of
things and this is of course the picture
that um you know mostly thinking about
the metal thing but there's other ones
they're reclaimed water that you're
using and I'll just leave it here Sean
and we'll can you give us just an old
overview welcome to the show give us
just an overview You Know Carl said you
know the way we're looking at things
really like to hear from you about the
kinds of things that the way you're
measuring things and the initiatives
that you're taking in these variety of
areas that you guys have embarked upon
there at Longwood sure and thank you
Carl Frank for having me on the show
it's a pleasure to be invited back
um so you're right I mean I think Frank
you you touched on some of this it's
baked into the culture of Longwood in
terms of my 24 years here we're going to
do the right things and so the right
thing might be it costs more up front to
do the right thing environmental and
sustainability so a good example is our
not our brand new longer to be imagine
project which is a 250 million dollar
project it's 17 Acres it's going to open
to our guests in November of 2024 lots
of initiatives we have in there
sustainability wise so we're going to be
capturing storm water coming from the
gutters and downspouts of our new admin
building and our Conservatory complex
which will then be used to help
supplement irrigation some of the water
features in the conservatory complex for
upgrading our effluent irrigation
treatment facility so that we can
utilize the the gray water if you will
inside our restroom facility so
something new to Longwood once again
trying to reduce our footprint into the
community of of using water from the
aquifer knowing that that's a big impact
for things so so Sean let me let me stop
you there so people hear this you have
your own
treatment operation in Longwood that is
that is correct and you are reusing that
water in the landscape that is correct
all of our outdoor landscape except for
a very small footprint is irrigated if
needed from a fluent irrigation during
the growing season so we use about three
million gallons of a fluent irrigation
for the turf grass for the plants for
everything outdoors in a year uh total
for all of them so this would be anybody
that has a um a building things like
that it's about 11 million gallons we're
putting back into the aquifer in our 40
acre flowing irrigation field so where
we we're treating it and then we're
putting it back into the aquifer to make
sure that we're replenishing that to be
good neighbors I mean it's the right
thing to do yeah yeah so so listen let
me Focus you a little bit on your
relaxed mowing that's what we we because
you also you know now you have this
paper out with land Scoot and for Danza
that's that's a CD group of
professionals to be involved I was a
grad student with Pete lanskoot at the
University of Rhode Island many moons
ago so
um let's talk a little bit about the
amount of land you've taken and put into
some form of relaxed mowing this is my
favorite picture let's talk about this
Meadow Garden first what what is this
thing about it it's so beautiful so this
is so this is actually this is our first
large-scale project from our strategic
plan that opened to our guests I believe
was it was either in 2010 or 2014 and so
it doubled the size of our Meadow from
40 acres to 80 acres and so the thought
there again was how can we open up more
of longwood's 1100 acres to the public
so we have about 350 Acres open to the
public and so with this you can see this
old historic house it's the web
Farmhouse it has an unbelievable exhibit
in it that dictates it or pictures I
will say of all of Chester County's
Agriculture and initiatives going back
from the 15 1600s all the way up to the
current day so it can paint the picture
of what Chester County looked like which
was rural agriculture back in the day
and so this Meadow if you will was is
low input right that needs that it's
recharging it in terms of the
groundwater
um we have an excellent land stewardship
team that maintains this and because of
this Meadow the longer reimagined
project the majority of the areas
outside that we normally would have turf
grass are going to be a similar Meadow
appearance to this so that we're doing
less input so we're not going to go back
with turp uh with turf grass in the
majority of the areas for this longer
reimagine once again thinking more
sustainability low input needs for this
okay you've this is great now
um this is tricky right
um
did you use chemicals in establishing
this thing do you have to go in and
manage it talk a little bit about this
we have some of this you know I as much
as I would really like to burn these
things on campus I just don't think
that's probably the best idea you do a
little burning don't you that's correct
so we said the land Searcher team
creates burn units and so this year I
believe they burn three different uh
sections that are in the meadow to keep
the invasives and also the Woody plants
out
um in these locations but they they do
use on occasion they will use herbicides
to if they need to to go in there uh
it's definitely not a zero input
landscape by any stretch but it's
monitoring maintaining and then also
assessing these areas by doing it if you
if you could if you could actually zoom
out on this area and look to see what it
used to a lot of the meadow used to be
an orchard back in Pierre's day and if
you could do to Google Earth you could
see where the orchard trees were planted
because the soil type is different and
so you can see the tree rings as you go
around and look at it it's really neat
to see in it unless you knew the history
you would never pick up on the circles
that were there as part of the orchard
into this original Meadow so as you guys
have planned to open the property to
more people rather than make it
intensely manage Landscapes like you
have at the formal Gardens right you've
embarked upon giving them access to it
uh but in in a in a pat it's a passive
access right I mean it's if people can
walk do you cut pads through these
things I I think Dan would tell you uh
that that having the pads having access
cutting around the paths uh maybe a pass
or two you still have to be intentional
about the way you manage these spaces if
you're going to allow access Sean can
you talk about that a little bit because
that's obviously an obstacle too for
people like on a campus and at a garden
where you want people walking all over
the place right no there is so so
there's pads that are cut through here
where we
where we want to stay on those locations
and so we try and create those paths
that are the most inviting takes them to
the areas of the of the property that
are the most interesting we also have
which you can't see in here we have
Pavilions which explain portions of the
meadow so one Pavilion is the pollinator
Pavilion it explains about pollination
uh we have other ones that explain about
the fauna in the area and they're
sprinkled throughout the meadow that we
have the paths we have are 10 foot and I
will say this just for anybody that's
willing to do this me being Turf
background I thought originally these
tasks have to be pristine perfect so
we're out there doing all of our
traditional Turf Care and after the
first year or two it was so popular
there was no way turf was staying on
these paths and so we we had to reset
our calibration if you will and say you
know what it's more like a park or a um
an event like that it could be compacted
soil it could have some Stone in it it
doesn't have to be a finely sodded turf
grass and that's what we don't have out
there anymore okay that's very
interesting so so that was it's very so
you were saying you're sort of turf
mindset is where you started but no
matter what you did it wasn't going to
put up with it no matter how wide you
made the pads they were too popular and
there was no way it was going to put up
but that's that's a little bit of oh I
got to get over my turf 101 training and
say you know this ain't working so big
kudos to think operationally and not
stay you know adamant like uh to to try
to get the grass grow in there now
um let's talk a little bit about what
Carl touched on with regard to
electrification
right uh Dan's Dan dabbled around with
it here uh Carl outlined it a little bit
um how are you doing it and you know are
you doing it wholesale how are you
thinking about integrating it into the
thing and and Carl showed the picture of
the robot but obviously that's going to
be a component of of a lot of our
operations coming forward let's talk
about electrification automation sure so
we have a lot of uh a number of years
ago we we really questioned the
traditional Torah Workman and the John
Deere caters things like that and so you
know those have a need at Longwood
because we have to have the hauling
capacity but if you're talking about
somebody that just needs to get from
point A to B or maybe on a regular basis
doesn't need the hauling capacity so we
quickly downsized and have a lot of
electric vehicles or electric uh carry
oils in terms of you're carrying
something small in the back so we've
greatly reduced that footprint most of
my outdoor landscape team which is which
is part of my new group under me if you
will they utilize all electric uh
handheld stuff so whether it's a
chainsaw or a hedge trimmers things like
that
they like them because they're lighter
and they actually have the ones we have
you can have like an electric battery
pack that's the best and so they don't
have the weight in their hands anymore
uh for that and with that you can change
out your batteries and you're still
productive all day because you're buying
multiple batteries and you're while
you're charging one you keep going with
it
sustainability committee that's going to
look at the whole campus wide and say
how can we slowly start eliminating our
pickup trucks that are gas powered and
start changing them to electric or some
other fuel source so we can reduce that
footprint as well
um we've thought about this at the
Greenwood Cemetery in Brooklyn where
I've been playing around the last six or
seven years and
um in discussions with the contractors
that are coming in to do the work they
were describing a wall of battery
chargers that would literally be uh 10
you know 10 by 20 wide of nothing but
battery chargers to keep line trimmers
and blowers of just the handheld stuff
going on a regular basis we obviously
were had a bit of a shutter at that and
then you know also having some solar
panels on the surface to Carl's Point
earlier where we getting the power from
that that matters as well can you talk
about for folks listening a little bit
about the logistics of having an
enormous volume of of battery operated
equipment that then has to be charged as
you showed as you said routinely during
the course of the day right so so you're
right so we build a as part of this
longer project we had to build a new
Horticulture equipment building which is
where the turf team and the outdoor
landscape team is headquartered and
um just because I didn't know enough
about it but we have so many electric uh
golf carts and vehicles now we had to
build a separate a building inside of it
if you will to house these batteries
because there's different standards for
them so you have to we had to have
monitoring for hydrogen gas that was
being given off and also venting that
would come on with different sensors and
so all of our stuff at this new facility
is kept into if you will their own
couple Bays that are just meant for
electric uh storage and recharging that
we have and then the the other thing we
did is most of the plugs we have come
down from the ceiling now so you can
plug into your chargers at the end of
the day but it was a different mindset
because you're right if you're going to
have all these batteries you need you
can't just store them in the old storage
shed and just plug into the outlet and
just walk away and forget about it and
so I think as we progress in Longwood
we're going to build more facilities
like this and start thinking of that
infrastructure needs and the safety
needs uh Incorporated with that
Carl I don't want to hog This brilliant
guy much more I got a waste question but
I'm gonna shut up for now that answer
that you just gave about battery is
worth the entire season of listening to
this baloney that we shot about every
week well done Sean this is I think you
know something that we don't think about
you know we're rushing Full Throttle
into this and not necessarily thinking
about it Carl what do you got for Sean
yeah I think that you know the Battle of
being a first adopter an early adopter
with some of these Technologies Frank is
is where we learn a lot right so we're
learning from you Sean you know it's
it's a it's a good thought to go to
electric equipment there's the
infrastructure that that I've learned
you know I went to a little conference
couple weeks ago where I learned you got
to be really intentional about how you
set up that infrastructure and how many
batteries you need a day and and maybe
even we could talk about uh the
challenges with the productivity if you
know I don't know if you guys are
heavily using gas power or electric
powered blowers now but a big concern
with landscapers and grounds operations
who do a lot of blowing material back
into the uh the native spaces uh have
you have you experienced those
challenges with drops in productivity
and having to sort of eat that that uh
drop in efficiency because of that early
adoption transition to electric
equipment
that's that's an excellent point and so
so far the pushback I've received is
more from the um the big leap blowing so
in the fall is that the productivity
isn't there with it with a handheld or a
battery power compared to the compared
to the gas powered one and so that we
haven't adopted fully yet but we're
going to have to get over that because
it's not just the fuel but it's also the
noise and so having 1.6 million visitors
at Longwood in a year you can't just go
out with a turbine blower at 10 o'clock
in the morning or at noon and because
the guests are coming here for the
reprieve of the the quiet the beauty and
if you hear that you're not having that
right and so we we are getting that
feedback now and so we need to start
looking at different ways of doing that
and then just the last Quick story so we
used to call it the magical lead
somebody on the west side of the
property would grow blow that leaf the
central part of the property but below
that lead the lead would end up at the
East side of the property and somebody
goes if you just picked it up on the
west side of the property you wouldn't
blow it three more times before it goes
into the woods and so we would always
joke around with each other it's like
just pick them up instead of blowing
pick them up so whether it's a back
system or something like that as you're
going around think of it differently and
don't just blow it to somebody else and
think they're going to deal with it down
the road yeah and this is again going to
the code benefits right Sean I mean uh I
know we like to focus on you know sort
of sustainability week here uh on the
show for us but it's not just carbon
dioxide emissions it's uh the noise
component is the biggest component when
I go down to landscapers in Rockland
County where there's blower bands and
everything uh people hate the noise and
that's like the number one concern down
there uh you know that Wisconsin uh you
know they're transitioning the zero turn
electric mowers one of the crazy things
is the operators have to have a horn on
it to let students know because they're
so quiet they actually gotta hey beep
beep I'm mowing here yeah um so there's
all these other co-benefits that I think
are important to think about not just
the you know the carbon emissions
and just like that 30 minutes is over we
got one more question Carl or are we
going to let everybody go so so here's a
good question from Ben polymer uh you
know we talked about the burning versus
maybe herbicide use and and the meadow
areas he's asking uh you know what has
more environmental issues uh selective
herbicides or burning that's a tough
question to answer Frank uh you know
when I think about it initially the
burning may be releases you know
obviously that's releasing some uh some
carbon dioxide gas right you're burning
organic material
um but it's maybe rejuvenating the stand
maybe you don't have to use the
herbicides later on Sean as you said
it's introducing the Woody plants the
invasives the herbicides on the other
hand are really quick they're designed
to degrade really really uh
fast in some cases they're selectively
yeah so it's I don't know if there's a
single answer to that Frank that's a
that's a tough uh tough question to
answer yeah I mean in a Perfectly
Natural system to your point
um when you burn you also get some
benefits to this weed seed bank so you
have long-term uh benefits makes the
grass stand more competitive and that's
going to be better for Less weeds
especially if you don't disturb it and
then uh the the weed seed bank is going
to be impacted a little bit Sean have
you ever noticed anything between where
you burn and have used herbicides well I
think they're very different I mean
they're two different tools and so the
one thing I will say when you burn if
you get a rainfall afterwards within two
weeks you're seeing green and so your
response back up again is ginormous
um with this in terms of the the green
up and and the the growth you're getting
I think you just have to think of as
they're they're two tools but they're
different in terms of what you're trying
to accomplish that's right all right
Carl Sean thank you so much for joining
us what a joy this was a lovely
conversation a great one for Earth Day
Carl you felt pretty good real
engineering topics today Carl right in
your lane brother the calculations are
right in my life and I have to go
through EPA documents two-stroke
four-stroke engines to figure out carbon
monoxide emissions that's right in my
wheelhouse
but uh but thanks everyone for joining
today uh we'll see you next week for
another Golf and sports show again
thanks to Sean for joining us and
talking about sustainable initiatives
take care everybody bye everybody
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu